ja sie ist in der Tat nicht allein und
für ein höheres Bürgergeld setzt sich
auch der Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband
ein der Hauptgeschäftsführer ist heute
morgen zu uns ins Studio gekommen guten
Morgen Ulrich Schneider schönen guten
Morgen Herr Schneider wir haben gerade
zusammen den Beitrag gesehen und da war
von einer Erhöhung von zehn Prozent die
Rede da haben sie schon gesagt 10% wären
ein Witz sie fordern ja 50% Erhöhung der
Grundsicherung aber das ist wiederum
nicht realistisch oder
politisch wäre es möglich das Geld ist
da ist die Frage will man es den
Menschen geben und will man uns nicht
geben zehn Prozent ich mache mal
deutlich wir haben im Moment für ein
Single fünf Euro am Tag für sämtliche
lebensmittelgetränke alles was er
braucht für ein Jugendlichen 3 Euro etwa
also jetzt von 3 € auf 3,30 € zu gehen
und damit solch ein Jugendlichen über
den Tag bringen ist wirklich ein
schlechter Witz nach unserem Berechnung
müsste der Regelsatz der Moment 450 rund
beträgt auf rund 678 Euro angehoben
werden um überhaupt den neuen eine
Chance zu geben von dem Mon zu bekommen
und nur wenn das passiert dann kann man
sagen das Hartz IV abgelöst und dann
habe ich es mit einem Bürgel zu tun wenn
es jetzt wieder nur Kleckerbeträge
werden dann sollte man besser bei dem
Namen Hartz IV bleiben viele
Empfängerinnen und Empfänger von Hartz
IV haben das Gefühl die Bundesregierung
tue nicht genug in diesen Zeiten aber
auch viele andere Bürgerinnen und Bürger
finden das auch wir können uns kurz mal
die Zahlen des ZDF politbarometers
anschauen hier ganz aktuell zu
Entlastung tut die Bundesregierung zu
wenig sagen 58 Prozent aller Befragten
und auch hier auf der rechten Seite
sehen Sie auch Anhänger und
Anhängerinnen in allen im Bundestag
vertretenden Parteien sagen mehrheitlich
die Bundesregierung Tour zu wenig herr
Schneider wo sollte denn die
Bundesregierung ihrer Meinung nach jetzt
jenseits von den Sätzen des neuen
Bürgergeldes ansetzen Wohngeld ein
wirklich ein wichtiger Hebel ist das
Wohngeld mit dem Wohngeld erreichen wir
theoretisch all dieser könnten sie
erreichen
die bisschen mehr haben als
Grundsicherung die also irgendwie durch
die Maschen fallen die aber auch nicht
viel haben die nicht wissen wie soll im
Monat kommen also wirklich arme Menschen
wir sagen wir haben im Moment nur
617.000 Haushalte die überhaupt Wohngeld
bekommen das muss erhöht werden auf rund
3 Millionen Haushalte dann hätten wir
wirklich für die untersten 20 Prozent in
dieser Bevölkerung eine echte Entlastung
geschaffen und das ist der Hebel den wir
alle empfehlen können und zwar nicht
erst im nächsten Jahr wie ist der
Kanzler jetzt avisiert hat im nächsten
Jahr wird was passiert sondern jetzt im
Herbst da brauchen die Menschen
Sicherheit und Zuversicht die Frage ist
ja wie das Ganze finanziert werden soll
das Arbeitsministerium hat das mal
durchgerechnet und kam auf Zahlen von
bis zu 1,7 Milliarden Euro bis zum Jahr
2026 und da sind eventuelle Erhöhungen
der Regelsätze noch gar nicht drin also
woher soll das Geld aber mit mal gestern
hatte Lindner der Finanzminister eine
Steuerentlastung von 10 Milliarden
vorgeschlagen insbesondere für besser
und Spitzen Berliner also offensichtlich
hat er Lindner das Geld und dann muss es
jetzt nur noch vernünftig ausgegeben
vor allem die Mittelschicht entlasten
was sie aber auch seinen Sinn hat das
sind ja die Menschen die am meisten
Steuern zahlen das ist Lindner Schritt
Tod die die Realität spricht immer von
der breiten Mitte tatsächlich fließen 90
Prozent seines entlastungsvorschlages in
die obersten 30 Prozent also zu
denjenigen die ich selber gerne als
obere Mittelschicht bezeichnet also die
die unten sind die untersten 30% geben
bei seinen Vorschlägen fast komplett
leer aus das ist Umverteilung von unten
nach oben was er will und wir sagen das
Geld ist offensichtlich da jetzt
vernünftig ausgehen und bei den Ansätzen
die wirklich nicht mehr über dem Monat
kommen ich glaube das Finanzministerium
hat die Dramatik der Situation in
Deutschland noch nicht ganz begriffen
sie versuchen ja auch in Interviews
diese Dramatik deutlich zu machen sie
haben letztens gesagt es drohe ein
verzweiflungswinter für die Menschen die
wenig haben und Zitat die
Bundesregierung habe es in der Hand ob
aus dem verzweiflungswinter ein
wutwinter wird finden Sie das sinnvoll
jetzt so eine Art Drohkulisse aufzubauen
es geht nicht um Brokkolis es geht darum
dass man der Politik wirklich vor Augen
hält wir haben es ja vorhin den Beitrag
gesehen von der betroffen wie
verzweifelt die Menschen gerade sind bei
mittlerweile ein fundbutter über drei
Euro kostet wenn die Menschen nicht mehr
wissen wie sie an der gemüse-theke noch
ein paar frische Tomaten oder Paprika
bezahlen sollen dann ist das was
Verzweiflung auslöst und was ich
ansprach ist wir haben es in der Hand
die Politik hat es in der Hand wenn sie
im Herbst vernünftige Maßnahmen auf dem
Weg bringt den Menschen wieder
Zuversicht zu geben ich habe gesagt sie
hat es nicht nur in der Hand ob da ein
gutwinn daraus wird sie hat auch in der
Hand ob ein Winter der Zuversicht
entstehen kann auch dazu muss sie jetzt
tätig werden und nicht erst im neuen
Jahr der Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband
fordert mehr Maßnahmen und eine
deutliche Erhöhung der Grundsicherung
das war der Hauptgeschäftsführer Ulrich
Schneider vielen Dank für das Gespräch
nicht zu danken